c'est ce manifeste souvent par des
angoisses on te dire
christelle papineau se décrit comme une
éco anxieuse elle qui milite depuis 20
ans pour l'environnement commence à
sentir l'impact des changements
climatiques sur sa santé mentale
l'élément déclencheur ça a été la venue
de mes enfants
donc ensuite bien on se questionne un
peu à savoir ben c'était une bonne chose
les à bormio mon angoisse d'impuissance
colère chagrin profond
les symptômes de cette anxiété
écologiques sont multiples et si
longtemps les militants écologistes ont
été les seuls à être atteints de cette
détresse
le phénomène est de plus en plus
répandue et des fois où c'est juste face
à l'ampleur de la tâche on devine
fatigué être découragé la multiplication
des catastrophes naturelles les études
scientifiques alarmante
les récents appels à l'action confirme
l'urgence de la crise climatique mais
contribue aussi alimenté cet éco anxiété
ce psychologue de montréal note une
augmentation des patients anxieux face
au sort de l'humanité
les gens sont très préoccupés par ce qu
on lit ce qu'on entend dans les
nouvelles et c'est dérangeant et
émotionnellement nous amène à être
maîtres de notre propre vie et le
problème n'épargne pas les jeunes
un stress qui les pousse même à revoir
leurs ambitions à remettre en question
leur choix de carrière
je m'imaginais avoir avant ma
belle-famille merci de penser ce que je
veux vraiment avoir des enfants dans le
monde comme ça ça me prime dans mon
choix de métier parce que je voudrais un
métier qui est coresponsable donc pas
quelque chose qui dans dans le marketing
quelque chose comme ça pourquoi comme
inciter les gens à consommer pour
contrer ce sentiment une partie de la
solution réside dans le militantisme
selon laure waridel le meilleur antidote
à l'éco anxiété
c'est l'engagement citoyen ce qu'une
panoplie de gestes qu'on peut poser
qu'ils font en sorte que en fait plus
partie des solutions que des problèmes
une façon de briser l'isolément et de
garder espoir et si jacques andré
charbonneau radio-canada mourir